un record absolu également en france
avec près de 200 milles 4 contamination
conséquence trois semaines de fermeture
supplémentaire pour les discothèques et
retour du port du masque dans les
centres villes en revanche et les
examens à l'université seront bien
maintenue pour les étudiants à la
rentrée c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
ministre de l'éducation ce matin adrien
fonteneau
le nouvel an approche est pour beaucoup
l'esprit est déjà aux examens le 3
janvier prochain les élèves de
l'enseignement supérieur sont appelés à
composer pour leurs partiels demi
semestre en présentiel san jose malgré
un variant mikron toujours plus présent
on a débattu de la question des examens
qui se déroule beaucoup au mois de
janvier cela a été tranché dans un sens
de présence en physique à ma
connaissance il n'y aura pas de jauge
dans les amphithéâtres mais cette à
frédéric vidal de le dire et cela
suppose aussi des dialogues avec les
présidents des universités et donc ça va
s'affiner au fil des jours face à ce
flou autour de la rentrée étudiante en
2022 les syndicats montent au créneau
avec une crainte sanitaire mais pas
uniquement on a des centaines et des
centaines d'étudiants qui sont positifs
et qu'ils ont en face d'eux deux choix
soit ils ne passent pas leurs partiels
et ils sont absolument pas certain
d'avoir un master l'an prochain soient
ils ils vont quand même composer avec
tout ce que ça implique c'est à dire
pour eux et s'ils sont malades c'est pas
des bonnes conditions d'examen et en
même temps leur est de causer des
clusters géant parce que c'est d'aider
les amphis de il ya autant d'étudiants
que deux places donc aucune
distanciation c'est pas parce qu'on a le
masque si on reste pendant quatre heures
dans un amphi ouvrir toutes les fenêtres
qu'on veut c'est par protocole sanitaire
adapté à la situation sanitaire une
situation sanitaire qui se dégrade en
france depuis plus d'un mois longtemps
similaires le taux d'incidence des 20 39
ans est aujourd'hui deux fois supérieur
à celui des 0 19 ans un problème qui
perdure même depuis la rentrée depuis
septembre on revendique d'avoir dans
toutes les universités de france des
masques et du gel distribuer
gratuitement des dépistages l'embauché
de personnel de santé et de professeur
en plus pour pouvoir faire des demi
groupe donc des logements importante et
faire moins de brassage on est depuis le
début de l'année il n'y a absolument
rien qui était fait ch la fac ça se
passe comme s'il n'y avait aucune
pandémie un sentiment d'abandon touche
beaucoup beaucoup d'étudiants qui se
retrouve presque à devoir choisir entre
leur santé et leurs études pas de
mobilisation pour le moment mais déjà
des pétitions à l'université panthéon
sorbonne un sondage mené par l'union
nationale des étudiants de france
confirme que des élèves même positif
pourrait venir aux examens